Speaker 1: All right.
I've been saying for some time, I think tomorrow's
election is the beginning.
I don't think it's the end of a phase.
I think it's the beginning of a phase.
It's going to be the beginning of a phase
in which Republicans take whatever wins they
get tomorrow and they're going to get some
we don't know how many.
We don't know what they'll control, but they're
going to get some wins tomorrow and they are
going to use those wins overtly to try to
set up a presidential election in 2024 where
they can't lose.
And what I mean by that is even if their opponent
gets more votes, they will try to find a way
to still get their candidate in the Oval Office.
It is increasingly looking like Donald Trump
may be that candidate.
Axios has published an exclusive report that
Donald Trump is planning to announce his candidacy
on November 14th.
Jonathan Swan reporting.
Former President Trump's inner circle is discussing
announcing the launch of a 2024 presidential
campaign on November 14, with the official
announcement possibly followed by a multi-day
series of political events.
Why it matters.
Trump and his top advisers have been signaling
for weeks that a 2024 announcement is imminent.
But the discussions reached the point that
allies are blocking off days in their calendars
for the week after the midterms and preparing
to travel.
Trump long planned to announce shortly after
the midterms, even toyed with announcing before
November eight to try to get ahead of rivals.
In recent weeks, Trump has been inching closer
and closer to straight up, saying that he
is running now.
It is possible that he will indeed announce
on November 14th.
It's also possible that he will announce tonight.
And the reason I say that is he straight up
said it last night at his rally in Florida.
Let's take a listen to what he had to say.
Speaker 2: I will probably have to do it again,
but stay tuned.
Speaker 1: So the crowd cheers for a while.
And then in a moment, we'll turn the audio
back up.
Donald Trump says, keep an eye on my rally
in Ohio tomorrow.
That's tonight.
And we're going to be live with that rally,
indeed.
Take a listen to what Donald Trump ultimately
said about it.
Speaker 2: That's pretty good.
Thank you.
Stay tuned to tomorrow night.
In the great state of Ohio State, we have
a big win, a big rally there for JD.
We have a big, big, big rally.
Speaker 1: Yep.
So it may be tonight.
It may be next Monday, but at this point,
it doesn't seem as if this is all for nothing.
It does appear as though he is setting up
a run.
And when I say this is the most important
midterm election I've ever covered.
A huge part of the reason is because it's
a setup election.
Well, that almost got that almost got dicey.
It's a setup election for 2024.
And I believe that the next two years are
going to be completely insane and we're going
to need to really be on our guard, because
by sheer stupidity, to some degree, they failed
to really come close to stealing it in 2020.
They're going to be way more prepared this
time around.
And we need to be ready for that.
I'll be live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook
tonight with the Ohio rally.
Also, we've got an Obama rally and then we
will have live election results tomorrow night.